I'm I'm Melissa O'Neal from Harvey Mudd
College and I'm delighted to be here
today to talk to you a little bit about
the PCG family random number generations
that's random number generators so I'm
gonna begin with a question for you'll
whether I like to have things be a
little bit interactive so I like to ask
the people who knew it is Oakley hand if
you've ever written a program that used
a random number generator so that's
basically everyone in the room and we
just for comparison let's say probably
have you ever written a programming
Haskell okay vastly fewer people but the
few people have actually said that they
they and so we could argue right that
this means that that you are far more
concerned about things like mind mm
generation than you could possibly be
about things like Haskell and it is the
case the random number generators are
actually everywhere in computer science
they used for cryptography they're used
for simulation they're used for games
they're used for optimization problems
they're used for all sorts of
computational creativity in fact at
Harvey Mudd College we have programming
languages class and we have a random art
assignment where it's all about
purportedly expression evaluation but it
actually produces cool like that so
random numbers are everywhere in
computer science and they've been there
pretty much since the beginning in fact
I'm going to begin by talking a little
bit about the history of random number
generation and ask you a question which
is how do computers generate random
numbers in 1927 and so some of you are
probably thinking hmm that sounds a bit
odd because I don't think there were
computers in 1927 but there were they
just weren't machines they were people
like you and and so and so yeah there
were it there were so here's here's an
example I'm holding up a book here of
something that was it was called tracts
for computers live seriously for people
who do computation is from
19:27 it's by Tippett and inside is a
nice collection of random numbers this
is how people would generate random
numbers and and in fact when this book
came out it received some criticism and
people were small paper say you know
these random numbers not quite so good
as you'd hope and so Kendall okay mr.
Kendall counting in the the mid thirties
he produced a much better book but the
same tracks for computers series and had
this actually had 10,000 random digits
in it and the reels are a culmination of
this this thing was this this book by
the RAND Corporation which was called a
million random digits and so this came
out in 1955 and so I have a question for
you which is you know given this this
thing does this does this make sense
I wanna actually point out that this
these are grouped in five so we could
also consider it a million digits or
200,000 five digit numbers my question
for you is its twofold one how would you
use a book like this and two does a book
like this make any sense to you at all
as a concept do it does it seem
completely fun I love people to be kind
of contrarian so I like you did sort of
talk somebody next to you I'm not really
gonna give you like less than a minute
probably but I'd like you to confer with
somebody new I possible disagree with
them so things I can confess I did this
this is concept of a book of rounder
numbers make any sense at all so talk to
each other
let me just ask I'm gonna ask those
folks for somebody to have a criticism
of this thing somebody who thinks that
the entire concept is is is flawed in
some way anyone have a criticism members
you need if you only need one any of
those books is acceptable okay so so
supposedly if we need you know more than
two hundred thousand random numbers that
would be that would be a problem so so
the size of the book might be an issue
any any other concerns look like that
was extremely useful back then for
making one-time coats okay so we could
so you could use it good question is it
useful for one for one time codes or not
yes your enemy is the same copy exactly
in fact in a bit this is the thing every
one of these books have the exact same
numbers in it and so you know it's kind
of a weird thing if you actually search
for this thing on Google we got lots of
hits for these numbers if you start with
these so these numbers put them into
Google you get a lot of our time you get
a whole bunch of you get a whole bunch
of hits also by the way this actually on
sale and I know that you can buy this at
Amazon still included and the the
reviews which is fascinating they
there's actually somebody who said
exactly what we're just talking about
saying you know I got one of these books
they're my Confederate got this book I
think was horrified to discover they had
the exact same numbers I I'm sending my
back and so it's got got wonderful
reviews on on Amazon can somebody make
some lemonade about the fact like we
said that maybe that's a problem
that these books have the same have the
same numbers is there something positive
that we can say about that yes well this
was done before the NSA so we know there
are no getting patterns ah yes so this
this is a really we can achieve this
name for this we can call this nothing
up my sleeve numbers but the thing is
what if you decide to use these numbers
on that and you didn't make the book you
can absolutely claim there's nothing up
your sleeve that they didn't just you
know
think there's no trick you know if
somebody else comes out with some
numbers oh these are my random numbers
you mean like more really but these ones
you can you can maybe have a more
confidence in that's a good thing we
will talk in a moment about whether or
not you know Holly exactly how these
were made and whether or not they they
kind of have any any pattern in them yes
it's really useful about having more
books with the same code as it gives you
the exact same results there's no random
number good right so one of the things
is that we get the if we use the same if
we use the same starting point and we
can get reproducible results which is
actually a really useful thing if if you
produce some results and you say oh I
just took some random numbers from
somewhere and we can be like really
really did you and whereas if you say
well I took them from this book and if
you want to replicate my results you
totally can that repeatability is a
wonderful thing so that's a that's a
really nice a really nice thing that we
have reproducibility that we can
reproduce the same the same results
these were generated from actual random
stuff I can actually show you here's all
the numbers of the glass by the way this
is all 200,000 numbers as a little
graphic and so we can say that they look
they certainly look random noise so so
that's that's a good that's a good thing
we'll come back we'll come to that but
these were generated there's actually
interesting they did they use a
technique that they called an electronic
roulette wheel was just trying to make
it seem like it sounded sort of
plausible to people but but they they
used that and and when they originally
did it they ran the machine and the
machine wasn't working quite right and
it produces stuff they didn't look
statistically random so they cleaned all
of the wheels and so forth on there
another little gizmos and eventually
eventually produce stuff that looks
pretty good like at a glance it looked
pretty good but even in 1955 people who
devote tests when they were criticizing
Tippit's book they developed tests like
the poker test which is like you kind of
simulate doing hands of poker and see
what the distribution of hands looked
like and so on and when I did that again
they found that things work actually
kind of disappointing that if you know
you couldn't see it there was some
subtle things there that it really
wasn't quite
around them as people will divide and so
the final thing by this point 1955 there
were electronic computers a lot of
people at that time used to insist that
you called them electronic computers to
distinguish them from the other kinds of
the real computers but they put it they
actually put it through an algorithm to
to make it so that they scrambled it up
and and did make it finally sort of
random enough to pass the statistical
test and that's actually a thing that's
often like the most naturally derived
randomness people do need to put it
through algorithms of some kind because
actual natural random must tends to have
some kind of bias of some kind and so
it's not it's not uncommon to you to
have to do that given that this was
produced by a machine and and scrambled
up afterwards and and so on and it
passed all these statistical tests we
could say it's statistically random does
that mean that we can't possibly predict
what's going to happen if I if I if I
start here and start reading off like
two three six one two five etc does that
mean that no one could know where in the
book I'm reading anyone think just even
though these books have no clear pattern
to them we could just store the whole
book and search through and find it in
fact if you just store some some kind of
markers every so often and that would
work too so it is reproducible and it's
and it's pretty even though it was
produced in a random way it's
predictable because we have the entire
book we could always search through the
whole thing
one of the things even though it was
statistically random for this method of
which I think many of you came up with
it and asked you about it but this
method of saying oh I'll just pick a
pick an arbitrary starting point and
start reading off if we do that let me
ask you a question about this this did
pass as a service in Sicily random
sample but if I if I pick a number here
what do you think the probability that I
picked a two should be it'll be one in
ten right that's what we that's what
we'd hope but because this is a random
sample of stuff in this machine it's not
quite one into a third one a 10 it's
it's kind of a little bit off in fact
we're 729 shy
of the right numbers nines and we've got
642 many twos now it's a random sample
that's sort of what you what what this
reasonable but it is a bit unfortunate
that this means that using this this
thing of picking arbitrary places in the
book it's going to be biased it's going
to be it's going to be but it's even
worse if we if we go to the look at the
five digit numbers in the in the book
because again you'd hope that with that
with five digits the odds would be one
in ten to the five that's what you'd
hope and so we'd average with 200,000
numbers but average to and we do a verge
two but there are four there are twice
as many five zeros and five 9s never
shows up at all and so if you're hoping
to randomly pick and get five nine
someday it's never gonna happen with
this book so that's that's a problem by
the way if you love the number sixty six
to twenty that's great that shows that
twelve times
so so that's that's great but back in
1955 when they had this they we already
said that they they put it through a
computer and people were already doing
fun things with computers so you might
say why couldn't they have done done
something different so let's consider
some other options they could have had
besides using your machine besides using
the hardware machine to do things so
here's one one option that they could
have done they could have taken some
some digits from PI and said well let's
let's use those as my as my random
digits so that we've got our digits for
pi ever know some people looking a bit
puzzled saying so what's that no I'm
sorry I think I guess I didn't mention
that this is the digits of pi starting
at their one point something trivia the
digit so no that wouldn't mean I didn't
actually do this from PI and they're
just further up so so yes that's that is
some digits from from PI and of course
we could we could I could have picked
some other starting point these these
digits from PI a little bit like the
golden ratio to those of you who love
the golden the golden ratio by the way
what do you how easy do you think it
will be
to find these things that its empire
how easy do you think it is to define
like you fight those is some there's
some fight how do you think that would
be so so assuming what like if you make
a wheel that we store the almost thing
yeah like old infinitely many digits
yeah I mean if I it's been awkward
because it does have a sort of it goes
on forever
but if we had a finite range and we
could we could store the the thing in
fact I I downloaded you know the first
the first two trillion and digits and so
all of the things I come I could come
from the first two trillion and so this
actually comes from fairly early on
actually but we could even have to do pi
we could have picked any any any real
number that's like my favorite so any
any thoughts about this as a strategy
that anything worse or better about this
as a strategy compared to them using the
machine they used for this book anyone
have any any thoughts about any cuts
about that like what kind of Gina they
used to make look so it was some
hardware that some electronics that
produce random random stuff so they
claimed what are you proven about them
so the the smart money and the math but
it turns out that it's really really
hard to prove things about randomness
but the the smart money is on this is
probably that ripped that numbers the
real numbers have almost all real
numbers something called normal which
means essentially that they look as if
they're completely random and the smart
money is that pie is is normal although
and everything everything that all the
evidence points to that but it has not
been proved but you know the same the
same is true for lots of other things
like it so it's empirically impaired
empirically it's as random as it gets
but it's not mean it's not being proved
it and it so but that's that's a thing
we could also claim that pie is the
ultimate nothing on my sleeve number
it's like this we could claim that while
we trust these people of around
cooperation they had nothing at burn up
their sleeves but we can sort of
that pie doesn't really have anything
anything up its sleeve so and based on
what we just saw about depending on
where I pick unless I've stored the
whole thing which starts getting
practical as we go more and more it's
not gonna be easy to predict so here's
some positive things that we can say
about pie
statistically the smart money of that is
that it's random it's an it's an
infinite stream it's like it's never
going to finish which is which is kind
of wonderful if I gave you some digits
you would have a hard time without just
doing an exhaustive search to find where
they came from we can get reproducible
results if we know where we're starting
from
and it's the ultimate last thing I
perceive numbers so it's kind of
surprising the hats like why doesn't
everybody just use pi as a thing there's
nothing up your sleeve you're depending
on somebody to do work for you we're
depending on the sort of the nature of
Pi but the but the thing is in the same
way that we picked around the starting
point we can pick around instinct we can
book an object I mean both of this book
and and PI we're using this thing sort
of like like as an amplifier for some
initial we could call it seed randomness
that we we pick some starting point in
then we read off random looking numbers
from that from that starting point and
so from that from that point it's if we
have an arbitrary starting point is it's
not gonna be it's not gonna be easy to
to predict what I think is the guy who
computed the digits of pi and the point
in the software
what do you can we can compute it a
bunch of different ways so that's that
is that's an important thing there so
and and in fact for people to to produce
it as a PI there's a whole bunch of
stuff about how you verify it and so on
well that's an interesting that's an
interesting question there's something
that was that is true for the book and
true for everything what we can say is
that the books and everything else there
they are I can amplify for some initial
randomness you could either always pick
the same point if you want reproducible
results or you can pick something
something cute like you know what day is
it today what's your you know and maybe
do some things with your friends do
whatever take it take a photograph take
the md5 checksum of it whatever you want
to do to produce some initial
non-determinism but the the key thing
about all these approaches right from
the the earliest one is there is they
are randomness amplifiers and that they
take some initial thing then they
produce reproducible randomness
to that so the big con really for using
for using PI it's just it's really
expensive execute it's like it's you
it's not it's not a cheap to compute
thing and so the actual the actually
issue with with practical random number
generation is doing it in a practical
way doing it in as little space and
there's a little time and still
producing good good results things that
satisfy all those statistical tests so
that's our sort of our our goal and what
we're gonna do and to kind of explore
this a little bit is we're just going to
invent a really terrible random number
generator so this is actually B
multiplied by three random number
generator which I hope you have a
sinking feeling in your stomach about
and so here it is and and here's here's
the output and by the way this is this
this mode is this this this kind of junk
rendered number generator has been
around since 1951 was we not using three
is the constant but anyone have a
criticism about this this sequence of
random purportedly random numbers yes
even numbers at all that seems that
seems like a problem although we could
always just divide by two or something
because oh but the night night night
night doesn't work this doesn't occur
group correctly so there are some
numbers that don't like I don't know
about 99 but I've checked the thing
they're awesome there are some that that
when you when you sequence them
differently there but that's like we can
get waking up to that questions at the
end so who are telling to the x 3 thing
we can actually say that they're all
they're all odd and in fact I was hoping
that somebody would suggest that they
are they're all multiples of 3 but
actually that's not true because we get
to the point where the things that's to
wrap around and so the numbers are
colored in red and not not multiples of
3 so there is a way if you really don't
like the fact that we're only getting
the odd numbers we can we can fix that
by just multiply by three noting one
that will that will get the job done
actually there's something not very good
about choosing there's some some rules
to these constants and so
well she's sort of multiplying by 3 and
adding 1 or multiply by 141 which is a
nice a number I had 3 just to keep the 3
in there and I also reduced the signs of
things to an 8-bit so we had we can see
the whole thing so if we if we look at
that that gives us the whole whole
sequence of of numbers and so this this
has been this is a 1960s technology here
and every number appears exactly once
which is which is a nice thing remember
how we had that issue with bias in this
book well this this is like a book where
there is no bias tomorrow right away we
start the because because everything
I've cursed once we're good we collect
property uniformity and so it's uniform
it's also a bit weird that everything
only appears once because I think you'd
expect there to be duplicates but you
know we're such a small thing what can
you expect perhaps anyone notice any
other any fours with this is no size I
missing something
are you doing this and then truncate
into three digits using in any
particular so good question thank you
yes the patio this goes it goes even on
even odd even odd even odd and so that's
that new could be you could be unhappy
about about the fact that it's breezing
you not in fact that's because the
period of the lower order bit is
actually just has two of two things like
0 1 the next bit of the period a bubble
bath which is slightly better and their
period doubles as you go to each
successive bit but there are any bits up
in the old form so we could complain
about that there's something on though
that that God observed in in 1968 some
of you may be familiar with this that if
you take the these numbers you group
them into pairs musa mets x and
y-coordinates and you pop them you you
get this very very rigid structure in
fact this is this is broadly a good sort
of structure for one of these things
that's called a linear this is called a
linear congruential generator and this
is more portly good one because although
they're kind of the in two dimensional
in two
they were actually reasonably well
spaced the normal forming nasty lines
sort of strike these stripey things so
but they're still you could say that I
think many of you would have a gut
feeling looking SPIE that doesn't seem
random to me and and I think that's that
sort of like this is it this get started
out a lot is like the poster thing a
poster child for video comprehension
generates like they've must be really
awful look at this it's terrible
and but I want you to just to sort of
not necessarily accept everything that
people tell you because one thing is
that we've taken a random number
generator that could only produce 256
numbers and then we plotted it on a grid
that has 65,000 points and be like I'll
try to fill this space would you random
number generator and you can argue that
it's like it's doing the best it can as
a 256 I think with your 56 states is
it's meant you know if it did it more
regularly there'd be gaps were stuff
never occurs and would that be would
that be better
and so Knuth when he looks at but he
looked at these things
he called this the grain of when you
come grant regeneration and I said well
that's that's just you know in too far
and and you you know and we can also
actually if you look at the order in
which these things occur they actually
occur in a in a kind of a fairly random
order and so maybe you can feel a little
bit better about this they can you sort
of this thing was all for but in it
maybe it's maybe it's actually a better
than you thought and in fact people
continue to use these things even though
people came up with those are the things
they and so here's a couple of really
classic linear congruential generators
following the two methods that we've
seen one is multiply by X by a number
and a decimal constant and then what
we've done is we throw an order those
thrown away the we've done it that 48
basins throw it away the lower one is 16
bits because they were really terrible I
had a really short period and and so the
in the other one is I'm just using
multiplication but I'm doing modulo some
some prime which which actually is kind
of scatters things around
reasonably nicely so DUI for you so so
these these things
actually have names this this one is
called D around 48 and the other one is
called ministered and they're actually
quite quite oh they one of them comes
from 1983 it was originally written for
pdp-11 a 16-bit machine some of you will
be a 16-bit machines and and so it was
kind of 48 was like three 16-bit
variables were used to make the the 48
bit and a number generator and mince it
came out a bit later the visit is a bit
interesting because it has a period
that's just shy of a power of two which
is kind of awkward if you're trying to
generate random bits because like you're
not quite matching up it's like in a lot
of computer applications especially
subsystem C ones we want random bits and
so it's nicer to have things where our
output is a 32 bits exactly and do you
write 48 can do that really nicely also
ministered has the issue that every
number only occurs once because the
period in the output range are the same
whereas in d round 48 every number of
curs 65,000 times and so we can we can
have we're still not biased for still
uniform and you might think well this is
great you what is telling me about this
stuff it's from the 80s I love the
eighties but you know how is this
relevant to me today well let me just
point out that do you I'm forty ages
java.util random and the other one is
C++ Elevens ministered Rand and but
clang and GCC use ministered as their
default random random number generator
so even today these are incredibly
prevalent it's also the case that
drivers added someone since this but
this lot of people still use Java util
random so given the flaws that we've
seen why why are linear congruential
generators so so prevalent well there
are lots of lots of good things about
about them they can be quite fast they
can support multiple streams the
constant that we add more lands where
you add a constant if you add a
different odd constant you know if you
get a completely different sequence of
random numbers and so that's kind of a
cool property we can scale into rfu
sizes and they support some other cool
things if you take the algorithm for
faster and exponentiation you can adapt
that pretty trivially
do jump ahead so you can say Oh what
number where I produce you know a
million time of million steps from now
and so they they support lots of nice
things and because there's a simple
venereal relationship methodically
they're really well understood and so
that's the positive thing but that that
grid still kind of like gets people in
the gut you know like yeah I don't like
that and so we really have to be be
aware that they are statistically
mediocre and because of the fact that
they they follow a simple mathematical
formula they are predictable that you
know Minnesota is obviously predictable
its state is is its output and even when
you drop the below order sixteen bits
it's trivial to figure out what those
lower to sixteen bits are with only 16
bits we just put force it and so it's
worth thinking about some of the
alternatives there are tons of
alternatives but we're going to focus on
the ones that are most well-known and
most popular today so one of the ones
that's really well known and and really
popular is the murder twister and it was
a tour de force when it came out in 1997
and it has an absolutely massive period
which means that if you were hoping to
use that technique of sort of memorizing
the whole book and doing a search in it
it's not gonna work for you it's only
not gonna work because like this is this
is vastly larger than the in fact I
should talk about how large this period
is because this book this is two hundred
thousand integers and I expressed it
graphically on the screen well what
we're gonna do is is imagine you know we
all have these little eye devices with
these retina displays and certain and
stuff so if I took that thing I shrunk
it down to a Retina display size about
that 200,000 things numbers would fill a
one and a half square inches on an iPad
on a Retina screen if I had two to the
32 integers that would be a generous
faculty office in fact I checked in at
Stanford that would be the beautiful
your tireless ceiling of a dean's office
with the iPad resolution things and
express their whole random sequence
there that way and that would be that
much that much space if I had to to the
48 integers all the all the numbers if I
laid them out on an iPad resolution that
would fill 150 city blocks if I
to 6400 just that would be the size of
Maine or Portugal or if you like you
like things think of things more
mathematically the radio as a sphere
with radius 53 miles the surface area of
that if we go up to 2 to the 128th
integers that is a sphere with radius
900 astronomical units that's that's 10
times the you know the the the radius
out of the here is the end of it edge of
the heliosphere which is like you know
so we're waiting compass in the entire
solar system and I didn't put it on the
side but if you do 2 to the 256 that
would be a sphere that is the same where
this is 10 times like our solar system
be 10 times the observable universe so
that's that's a pretty huge period and
the Mosin twister is way way way bigger
than that so an approach where you just
search through the things is completely
impractical so that might seem kind of
cool as I said I think I said it was
like mathematically also it had lots of
like this is are mostly systems eolian
so I can say to you it's really scary
Matthew rule so so that seems that seems
kind of positive but unfortunately there
were some some issues one is the it's
it's huge for a random number generator
just like it takes two and a half
kilobytes anyway I think well what's to
not have kilobytes but if you wanted to
embed a random number in your data start
generator in your data structures you
know that's gonna add up if you decide
to use multiple multiple random number
generators it's not that fast actually
and really really crazily if you just
even despite the huge number of numbers
it can produce if you just get 624
numbers from the Mersenne twister from
that point onwards you can predict it
completely which is really kind of sad
so it also has some other some other
issues and and it's not the only random
number generator people can already the
Mersenne twister was produced for python
was gets used by python lots of other
languages but there are other people who
have picked other ones and what another
popular one is one called XOR shipped
which was produced by the same person
that actually came up with the that
horrible diagram that showed how awful
linear congruential generators were it
is a bit awkward that it have got minus
1 on the on the period is kind of like
yeah that's a little bit annoying it's
incapable of producing zero essentially
like the zero stages as death stated it
hates that so and other people produced
other random numbers but then other run
other random number generators but
things look pretty good just like you
could tell people well if you I want
something really big use the mother
twister maybe and if you want something
a bit smaller you could use X or shift
and things were looking pretty good in
the world of random number generation
until 2007 and in 2007 one of the the
meeting lights and random number
generation somebody in Montreal called
PLA QA decided to people have been
coming up with statistical tests for run
a number of generation for a long time
ever since you know Tippit's book first
came out and in 2000 2007 PL akyurek
took at one only search further and he
found about 160 different random number
of tests statistical tests that you
could apply to run a number generator
and he developed a a test suite called
test uo1 and the idea was it was a
rigorous a rigorous thing to put random
number generators through to see how
well they would do how many of all of
these statistical tests they would pass
and not surprisingly when you take a
look at when you come around to
generators they they did not pass he did
three different batteries one called
small crush that runs in about 10
seconds and so small crush in 10 seconds
were you like run 15 tests and some of
the new comprehension others just failed
on 15 this point boom failed everything
and and he also had two others media
crush and big crush and big crush takes
about six to eight hours to run and does
much more like a much more intense test
but but before your comprehension or
just couldn't even last 10 seconds it
wasn't just linear congruential
generators either
they there were various other ones a lot
of people think that the UNIX random
generation scheme should be better than
things like Duran 48 it you can see here
it's actually worse fells more
statistical tests X or shift also fails
at least in its 32-bit incarnations so
that's that's pretty bad and that's just
the ten second test what about the one
that runs for eight hours well
almost everything felt big crush like
certainly the ones that anyone anybody
ever used felt big crush there are some
easy Taric ones that not necessarily
practical like we could use pi that
would that would have passed but but the
but all the ones that people actually
use note they those that it was kind of
decimated the field and that was kind of
surprising because some people you know
really love things like the Mo's
interest they had it was beautiful
mathematics and stuff but unfortunately
mathematics can't capture all the
properties that you might you might care
about and around another generator and
and in particular all the techniques
that are based on something called a
generalized linear feedback shift
register design there's a test the
vicinities smith test for this thing
called a for that kind of friend of nova
joker mmm mmm you smell like a when
you'd liked your photos day yeah i know
i know your thing and so that's there is
a test called linear complexity that
performs that that test and that's part
of the big crush sweet for some reason
it's not part of small crush even though
it actually doesn't take very long to
run so just because i'm a cruel person I
took that test out of out of big
crushers like I just run that separately
and see see what it does with these
these ones and it turns out that if you
run the linear complexity test on a
bunch of these these ones that you know
really well respected in the literature
they all they all fail and they fail in
about you know six to ten seconds and
for the amount of Twister you just need
forty five thousand random numbers from
it and they say move sorry you know
you're you're no good and because you
can react to that by just saying oh well
that test I mean really who would run
that test but you know then there's it's
still kind of ashamed that these these
things failed this for the statistical
test so you could argue that that's kind
of a shocker but there's there's even
more of a shocker in this because
remember how awful linear congruential
generators were well it turns out that
if you go up to a 64 bit winner
congruent to generator and throw away
the low order 32 bits that part is small
crash and if you go out to 96 bits that
passes big crash and order to make the
96 bit one it's not even hard we could
take that ancient code for D 148 just
upgrade it to use 32-bit installer than
64 bit in Sandton are we you know
like it's not hard to make a 96 bit
linear congruential generator so then
this is this is something that's true
for some of these generation schemes
that for many of them more bits makes it
easier for them to pass statistical
tests and fewer bits makes it harder and
you can kind of see through intuitively
why that might be the case if you no
matter how good a generator might be by
crashing down to having a single bit of
state it's pretty clear that it couldn't
pass very many statistical tests with
only a single bit of state and so it's
it's quite it's kind of matches our
intuition that having more bits might
make it easier for things to pass and it
turns out that linear congruential
generators actually pass at 88 bits so
if we throw away the load of 56 bits
keep the top 32 we we actually will pass
that big crush test but it's not true
this property isn't true for everything
sadly exo shift fellas know about how
many bits you give it and the most
twisted it's like how huge it was it
still fails that the sniff test doesn't
care how big you are it's like no matter
how big your is like no your your linear
feedback shift register so that's cool
but 88 bits you might think well maybe
that's as good as you can get but I
think if you if you do some theory
that's in the paper I want to talk about
it today you can actually determine that
the the smallest a thing could be if it
was uniform the smallest it and looking
at the properties and how this
statistical test works and so forth
suppose it could have be actually 36
bits and 88 is quite a quite a big quite
a way away from 36 bits and in fact a
variant of X or shift exhale shift star
passes big crush if we just keep do judo
forty bit size and keep the top 32 throw
away the bottom the bottom eight you
might say well what is when you don't
even necessarily know what X or shift is
but what's like so ships star well it's
just
XO shift plus an improving step so all
were doing is we're doing something to
to make it to make it a better and and
what is this improving step
well crazily enough what we do is we
take the internal state and we multiply
it by number and that's the improving
step that step that exertion if star
does its is actually taking the trick of
a linear congruential generator and
saying I'll just
that trick to get thee to get the job
done and and so the state is is still
this this shift register thing but to
get the output it's doing this extra
step and this this gives is a kind of a
something that's that's a useful
property about run another generation
it's like what the internal state is and
what the output is don't have to be the
same we can tweak the internal state to
producing the output so what would we
did with D 148 is we had internal state
there was 48 bits we threw away 16 bits
and kept and kept the top 32 but you can
also do scrambling
that's what XO shifts star does no and
instantly that's what the Mersenne
twister also does although it's
scrambling doesn't stop it from failing
with the sniff test and obviously you
could combine those together to make
something that both drops bits and and
scrambles things but no matter how we do
this we should make sure we don't
introduce bias so you might notice on
the on the we never have it's always the
case that it's always Kate one so in
these in these examples it's two to one
that two things not every everything the
output has exactly two things that map
to it although if we did something
different from that we'd introduce we do
introduce bias so that's an idea that we
got in the output doesn't have to be the
internal state we can sort of per muted
in some way and there are three possible
things that can happen if you permute
the output if the thing was already sort
of truly random in some sense it
couldn't possibly change it to to put it
through any kind of by ejection wouldn't
make it any less random than it already
was but if you if you have something
that is not quite random enough and you
put it through a suitable scrambling
function then that might make it seem
more random and that's what we did with
XO shift and obviously you could make it
worse in fact if you'd already put it
through that that multiply and you put
it through this other one that's the
multiplicative inverse and so that would
turn XO shift star back into excerpt
again but obviously if we dropped some
bits then it might be harder to invert
the the transformation but it leads to a
fairly sort of obvious question which is
like well if we if we're allowed to do
some stuff to improve X or shift
surely I should be allowed to do some
stuff to improve a linear Honka Honka
generators only oh it stands to reason
and so let's let's see if we can come up
with an idea here what
to do so we know we want 32-bits we know
the low wood bits are terrible like the
lowest would have it is just going zero
one zero one zero one which is not not
very good at all and but they get better
as you go further up do you run for do
just throw away the the the low-order
sixteen bits we could just for with a
64-bit one just throw away the the
bottom thirty-two bits and we tried that
and that passed small crash did not pass
big crush but here's here's the idea you
could say well maybe the lowest ones are
really terrible and maybe in some sense
these top ones are sort of like the best
but these ones next door they're not
they're not the worst random number
generated numbers in the world they
they're they're kind of they're pretty
random and the ones next to them they're
pretty random too if we were using those
that would be not quite enough to passed
all the tests but they'd be pretty good
these ones over here not quite as good
but they're and so I've got a bunch of
different places I could choose some
bits from and so instead of just always
picking from the same place why not
instead say oh I've got a bunch of
different random number generators over
here in these bits let me let me use
figure out some way to choose and how
should I choose hmm what kind of a
girl's do we like I love randomized
algorithms so I should pick randomly hmm
okay but where am I gonna get any
randomness from if only I had some
really good high-quality randomness
somewhere that would really helped me
right well these are like the best
because these top few bits are the best
best bits out there so we could just
take those three bits and say I will
pick a where to go based on those those
bits so when these bits read to I will
pick the this place here I'll pick the
the point that's that is let me let me
show you again I'll show you again on a
16 bit example just so that we can be
clear what's going on so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to say first of all
let's remind ourselves that this was
actually for a terrible 16 bit I mean
your comprehension generator so it's
gonna be really stripy so if we plotted
all the points that you get out of these
these type bits it looks like that
I went to the next one it looks like
that so until next one it looks the same
still very stripy next one is kind of
and if you can see in the particulars
kind of dotty and the next one is is
even more dotty and so on and what we're
going to do is in this case because only
16 minutes going to use the top two bits
and I'm gonna pick and use those to
choose which of these for now because
I'm using the top two bits it means that
these my very best to random number
things that are gonna be out so they're
out of out of the picture but these top
two bits are going to be causing me to
switch depending on the value of our top
two because I'll be switching between
these these other three things and they
those are all terrible and so the
question is what do you get if you
randomly switch between them what you
get is that now you might look at that
and see like I can still see some
structure there and you'd be right there
is still some structure there but in
terms of like at a gut level does this
feel more random to you than the
individual things I think you'd say yeah
it's like those are the ones we're very
very very regimented in their stripes
and this is this is this way of
switching between things is seems-seems
at a gut level like it might be better
and so the nice thing is the code for
this is super simple because if we had a
standard 64 bit Liam hog Rancher
generator we've just dropped the load of
32 bits we can just take that home runs
take this fixed shift of 32 bits and
switch it down to just saying well I'll
use a top the top few bits to decide
what my ship should be and that's it
that's that's the only difference in the
in the code and the cool thing is that
this thing path is big crush and it does
so at 58 bits which is cool so it means
that you can have a 64 64 bits of state
produce 32 bit random numbers and you're
passing big crush with you know six bits
to spare which is which is kind of you
know like you could have you could which
we can sort of gut-level we could say oh
I could double the size of the test and
double it a few more times I'd still be
passing that's just one idea let's let's
consider some another idea because you
might remember let's let's say we're
going to think about just this range
which is this little
peace here on the on the I say I'm
actually just going to throw away those
those button that's what a few bids and
pick and use the the top bits to give me
a number between zero and seven and so
there there is going to be my my number
and I'm going to use that to pick this
time so I'm getting eight bits out of 16
I'm going to use it to pick a rotation
because it will always the case that the
Lowood a bit was like the the worst one
I'm gonna plate like rude around where
does it go nobody knows like that
terrible bit it's gonna move around and
so I don't view rotations now if you
look at what it does to the lattice it
does horrible things because moving that
load a bit up too high to make it really
significant there's really really nasty
things but and so none of these look
very random or very nice at all
but if you combine them together again
you get something that looks pretty cool
and what's neat about this is again this
part is a big question but does even
better it passes at 53 bits but you
still might be concerned you might think
well okay this is all very neat but how
do you know you're not introducing bias
or something something strange here and
so let's think about that so let's think
about our our process here that we were
doing we were taking a bit pattern we're
going to look at the first the first few
first three bits and we're going to use
that to decide on a rotation and so in
this case the rotation was two and so we
move that the two bits around and so
that's where we're at at the at the end
and the question is how do we know that
this this transformation is a
permutation how do we know that it is a
bijection and does anyone I don't have
an argument for why how you can know
this must be a bijection you can
that way to tell the commutation is that
you can you can you can undo it
that's a conditional permutation so why
don't we say conditional permutation you
mean it's driven by the circuit it's
driven by those top those tough bits cuz
I don't have anyone having an argument
for how you know that this this is this
has to be a by section one one thing you
say we can say that we can we can know
it is if we can if we know we can undo
it do you know that you can undo it you
could do it the other way what's the
right what's the recipe for doing that
you just look at the top base and do the
reverse in the other direction and then
you're back where you started so this is
obviously invertible and so we could
look at this one and say I know that
this this one is invertible and we know
that it's a bijection but we can
actually generalize this and just think
about this in general I would have a
little bit a little bit of math there's
more if you love intimidating methods
more in the paper but the piece of you
paper but what we're going to do is
we're going to consider these these two
parts of the thing as a tuple as a pair
and in general I'm going to consider the
top part in the bottom bit permutations
on a cross B so that's so we're just
thinking of this this thing as a as a
pair and the most obvious permutation
that you could do by ejection that you
could do it on a pair is you take two
permutation functions one that turns
that permutes the a is one that commutes
the B's and you just apply them both and
that would give you a permutation on on
the both but that that sort of is not
what we were doing what we were doing
was something a little bit different so
what we did is we concentrated all our
effort on one side we said we had a
family of permutations in our case but a
family of rotations we had eight
different rotation by 0 by 1 by 2 all
the way up to 7 you had a family of
permutation functions and every one of
them is a permutation it can be inverted
and there's one for every every member
of a the things on the one side of our
tuple and if we have that family then
it's also the case the
if we apply it if we apply it by using
this F style or we say F star of a B is
a followed by F of a F a of B then that
is a permutation for exactly the same
reasoning that we had before they you
can undo it that we can just apply the
inverse of the permutation two to undo
it and so that gives is a really
powerful way to perform permutations
using the randomness that already exists
in in our in our random bits we can use
the high order bits and use them to
perform whatever permutation we've
picked some simple things we picked
things like rotations and and shifts but
you can do you can do other things too
and that's kind of a neat a neat idea
and this is this idea of applying
permutations in general and in
particular these particular cool kinds
of permutations is what underlies this
family the I produced which is the PCG
family which stands for muted with a new
controversial generator and so in the
PCG family you just start with a base
then you come around to generator
because has lots of cool properties all
the things like jump ahead compact size
etc almost all pretty good and then we
just add that little extra magic of some
permutation stuff on the end potentially
with that permutation we're also
dropping some stuff dropping some bits
which means that the permutation guys
should be hard to in we're gonna get a
case one transformation that's hard to
invert because you you don't know what
the what the busy last word so that's
what that's what happens with the PC
Gephart PCG family you can beget you
could just do a random shift or a random
rotate that gives you some stuff but we
can combine them we can stack one place
one permutation atop another and do even
better so that's the sort of theory but
what about the practice how well do
these things actually perform in
practice well we're going to begin by
thinking about predictable 32-bit
generators now but everything in this on
this thing except for the Mersenne
twister only has 32 bits of state just
four bytes of state tiny tiny amount of
state and we're asking it to produce 32
bits of output so
it cannot hide anything it can't throw
anything away by definition you have to
be able to all of its permutations must
be invertible you can get back to the
state unless you can predict them so
they are going to be predictable and
they're going to be small so how how do
these do well in terms of speed you can
see there that this is the in gigabits
per second and the PCG repeat this this
particular pc g1 which stacks three
permutations together is actually would
happily saturate 30 gigabit ethernet
lines which is kind of cool at 30
gigabits per second which is which is
pretty neat and what about statistical
quality cuz that's something else we
said we we should care about well these
ones on the on the right hand side they
they failed small crash and the ones on
right hand side they passed small crash
which is which is cool no it's a tiny
tiny generator so we already said that
you couldn't possibly pass big crash
without with fewer than 36 bits so we
can't expect we can't expect the 30 to
be generated to pass big crash but does
pass a small crash which is good and so
does the Mo's and twister it's much
huger it doesn't pass big cut either but
for know no good reason really so that's
that's a thing what we might say well
what about big crash though how big do
you have to get to pass big crash well
we know we know that the Mo's and
twisted doesn't pass big crush we know
that even though you can change the size
of EXO shift no matter how big we make
it it never passes that that that test
we know that X or shift we said that
that actually did pass if I keep the top
32 bits throw away the low eight bits
that passes so what if what if the PC
degenerate how does that how does that
do well that one passes at 36 bits which
is really really cool
and so that's so we've got something
that's both fast and statistically
really really good and so that's that's
kind of cool unfortunately though this
this one because it returns all of its
state is well the the 32 people are not
the 36 bit
is resetting all the state that's
predictable I could also show you how
Minster does because it's kind of
fascinating Minster is just a linear
congruential generator and so you might
be like wait a minute I know it wouldn't
pass statistical test but surely it
should be faster because it's not doing
these permutation things that the PCG
ones are doing so how on earth could pc
g be faster than the learning
comprehension generator that doesn't
make any sense
well the the answer to that is midst it
actually includes a modulus by a prime
in it and that means we're doing a
division operation and that's slow and
so if you do all these permutations in
the time that it takes easily in less
time that takes to do the division
in C and C++
and I could people have implemented them
in other languages but yes sir this is
we hope we'd hope that these would be
would be first you got to 64 bit
predictable generators again we're
giving all 64 bits as out of our output
you might again you can you can see that
the graphs appear almost identical and
across these things and XO shift we know
that's gonna fail tests we also know
that the Mersenne twister jar
statistical test as well but you might
be surprised given everything we just
said previously about it passing at 40
bits that X or shift stop fails at 64
bits as well that's because I'm using 64
bits of state and I'm asking for it to
give me all 64 bits of its state and
then load of bits in XO shifts star are
still not very good so it you can't you
can't just return I just returned those
so if we go if we go to a point where we
start dropping some bits this isn't a
harder to predict ones was the last last
light of performance stuff you can you
could see here that the X or shift is
again
not doing very well in terms of
performance they're either either at
speed or it's a statistical goodness and
these are these other ones are doing a
bit better they these are all passed
Cisco tests I've added a new one on to
the diversity of added opt for a random
which is its whole reason for being is
to be hard to predict it's a it's a
cryptographically secure random number
generator and so it works really really
hard to do lots and lots and lots of
scrambling to be really sure that nobody
could possibly back them back the thing
out of course all that amount of
scrambling that it does makes it really
really much much slower than everything
else and it's not clear that you need to
do that much even though that I wouldn't
say that that this that the PCG one
that's hard to predict is the is the
most hard to predict PCG one there are
ones that are quite hard to predict that
don't try nearly as hard as our four
random does but if you're doing
cryptography maybe you want to over
engineer things a bit also alpha random
is kind of old there's there's a new one
called ChaCha twenty that people quite
like and that runs about twice as fast
as out for random so that's good for a
cryptographically secure generator that
people happy with but it's still kind of
still kind of slow actually the
statistical properties of those ones are
not as well understood as some of the
other ones so that's a little bit about
the performance of things and if you
want to know more about things you can
go to PCG random.org there is a paper
there is code and most importantly there
is part there are party tricks and one
of the things I haven't talked about at
all is an extension technique using the
permutation stuff that allows you to
extend the period pretty much
arbitrarily on a on a base generator and
so we can go to if you love really
really huge generations that have
massive massive bits of state you can
you can totally have that and there's a
property called k2 Mitchell equal
distribution which means that every K
tuple occurs the same number of times
you can have that too and with that you
can actually have crazy things like
generators that have insanely huge
periods but also you can set them up so
that they're just on the verge of
putting out a zip file that contains
Shakespeare which is kind of a crazy a
crazy thing to do it's kind of fun and
I'm gonna finish up as my last thing to
do since we did fun stuff with
permutations we might remember we had
those awful drawings that main linear
congruential generators will look bad I
thought it'll be already fetched try to
make my stuff look bad
so let me to do is I'm going to try to
improve about the worst possible random
number generator you could possibly
imagine by applying one of these
permutations so this is the ad 1/16 bit
random number generator I think your
degree this is not very random to start
with and this is horribly mean to my
permutation techniques because they they
they expect the top bits to be the most
random then Avista random when you're
adding one they hardly ever change so
this is really horrible so what does it
look like well that's what it looks like
I think it's I think it's kind of kind
of fun so that was and if we go to a
slightly different number is adding
three that's that's what that looks like
and if we go to adding five that's what
that looks like that was that was the
one where it's doing a random rotation
and it's kind of its kind of cute it
looks pretty fractal be there was
another one that could pass at 36 bits
well if I take the one where we add five
it's going to look a little bit better
but it's still we're still being really
mean to it because it's expecting the
top bits to be the most rounded and
they're totally not and so it's kind of
got a bit of it still looks pretty awful
but if we just take the thing instead of
adding five I don't know if it's
actually going to change the high order
bits that permutation gives you the idea
of how powerful the permit that
permutation is that if we just we're not
really using a properly in your conv
Ranchi generator we're just adding a
constant but it still looks pretty good
looks pretty random and so these things
sort of remind me that's random stuff
and ours and that's pretty much where we
began the talk that seems like a good
place to end it so I'll just ask if
there are any questions like stay into
two parts and then you aim to generate
leg to commute be like I wonder why like
stop at two like can you use FFP to PSD
for the next part to do you say can you
go back to like when you have like
Disha yeah or some other permutation
yeah with that increase like randomness
or so if you see you're saying is the
permutation to be some other
presentation in the same way so you can
things you can set these up right so so
one of the things that you can do is you
can you can I mean you can use one thing
to change the you can you can use the
lens times lights change the right hand
side then you can having to use the
right hand side you can change their I
don't use the right hand side here's the
left hand side and so on
in fact there's sort of I think a bit
like that which is might go by too quick
for people to follow but there's a thing
that people say like how many bits of
randomness do you need to shuffle a deck
of cards and they might say well I must
need 50 52 factorial sort of stuff to do
52 53 factor because that's how many
permutations there are the correct
answer or a different answer is is none
at all
because you have a deck of cards and
stay at the deck of cards represent
things and so you can use TCG
permutations to say I'll I'll use the
front or consider the front in the back
of the cards I'll look at the state of
the front I'll use that commute the back
then I'll use the state of the back to
permute the front then I'll use the
state of the edges to permute the middle
and then I used to say to the middle to
permute the edges and that means that I
can give it a particular configuration I
can shuffle the Kart deck in a unique
way that's unique to that configuration
and that doesn't guarantee you that you
go through all possible permutations
there's an extra trick that you can do
on the top of that because this isn't
you can invert it so you can actually
you can count through every possible
permutation in a very regular way but as
you do that you Cather in a regular way
then you've you permitted in a unique
way to some crazy combination that you
permute it back can't advance it one and
you can conceive in advance in a crazy
way through all possible permutations in
the deck of cards by doing that stacked
that idea of stacking fermentations one
on top of the other so so yes and in
fact you know that's that's a good thing
to do the one thing that you can't do is
that you can't you can't with a on
the
when you're when you're applying it so
you have to wait until you're done with
that with that step because you can't do
anything that will prevent you from
inverting it you can't mess with a in
that step okay another question yes all
the people have heard talk about random
numbers talk about the infinite stream
and it's statistical coffee but they're
often you don't want me the whole stream
you want a very small subset because
you're asking a simple thing and many
years ago I was working on the UNIX
fortune program which reads a fast buck
bottom chooser and line up and I noticed
that regularly it was in my login script
I would see the same handful of fortunes
over nori and I tracked this down to a
fundamental problem with seeding around
another generator because the seeding
process was was just not able to find a
random place in this actually fit stream
and we've tried everything we could
think of and there were amazing spikes
may begin you're supposed to go across a
distribution for the pieces you get out
but there were spikes out here like this
and the only way to get them to come
down all was after you seed to run for a
million or two million directions and
see if you can get somewhere but it's
totally empirical I've never heard
anyone actually try that that's the
problem speeding generally the seating
people have investigated the question of
seeing we sort of like elided it because
we said you know people were doing
seeding back up back in the day when
they had these these books and so we
sort of didn't spend a lot of time
thinking about how you do seeding but
there are ways there are ways to get
decent entropy and I would love I would
look I could give I give a whole
separate different talk on how if you
want this is this is about deterministic
generation and there are there are way
and I'm happy to chat to you afterwards
but there are some ways to guarantee and
some so actually surprised I'm actually
gonna tease people with it just because
I can tease people with the thing that I
think I can actually show you a program
that takes no input at all and produces
a different value every time you run it
that is actually statistically random
and the and what I when I want to show
that to people as always a really
interesting conversation
because I they're like oh cool okay so
does it to look at the time then I'm
like no it takes no input and oh okay
cool
does it go out on the web no it takes no
input like because people understanding
of how computers work doesn't doesn't
allow the idea that this is this could
be possible so some of you might know
how how it's done but I'm just gonna
leave that as a teaser for for people it
is it is a thing that you can you can
you can write such a program
but yeah seeding seeding isn't
interesting is an interesting thing one
of the things I show you in the in the
practical side of the PCG generation
scheme is it has some things to actually
help you see things well it has things
to help you do seeding well using things
like the random device to make it really
really easy to do to use that it also
has stuff where it can leverage it has
something called PCT unique where
depending on where the the generator is
located in memory it chooses a different
stream and if you use PCG unique on a
machine that has address space layout
randomization actually PCG unique will
give you different numbers every time as
well so it's it is it is an important
issue and doing it well is something
that it's much nicer if the libraries
that you use just have stuff that takes
care of it for you and one of the big
problems with a lot of random number
stuff is that people don't don't get
those those they're just like oh just
come up with a seat and some people do
it well and some people like oh just use
the time or whatever it is in this like
it doesn't that doesn't necessarily
produce good results good question I
tell people after after afterwards like
the non and the non video part of the
talk people people at the camera thank
you I'm terrible there is so people are
watching a video of ha
your being here so it is kind of a known
thing yes I tend to think one of these
people is gonna have to turn or left
super randomness and so I'm use nuclear
decay is one and I guess thermal noise
is the other but I found out that the
hardware I use is not I mean the thing
is there's all the things one of the
reasons why people came out with these
books originally is that you might think
that the physical world would be great
for producing randomness but is actually
actually really bad at producing sort of
Cisco randomness there can be problems
with the hardware and so forth and it's
can we get people to roll day a day it's
gonna be they can introduce bias
surprisingly and and it turns out that
it's not you know it's it's not it's not
better the other funny thing is of
course you know they if you look at how
much University how much randomness the
universe can possibly produce it's less
than these random number generators we
look at so that's also kind of like a
wacky oh why he thinks beats are not
random therefore computers are not
random or these I guess in the
definition of what what we mean by
random and if you get to the point where
you say if you say it's random if we if
we can have things that are massive
statistics and without some kind of
omniscient view we can't predict what
they're going to do I think we'd all
agree that computers actually are pretty
random in that sense we can weekend like
a lot of a lot of debugging is it's like
trying to figure out what on earth it's
doing and some of those things can be
gonna be quite challenging might have
many different sequences and generators
acting so one of the things that you
might want in a parallel in a parallel
situation is you might want to have it
doesn't make sense to have a global
random number generator in power system
because it's gonna become bottleneck and
so that's one of the things that's a big
issue for things like the most and
twisted is like if you just had one
global one maybe two and a half K of
stage like yeah
in whatever but if you if you want to
have every every thread have its own
random number generator then you you
probably want that's that's a thing to
want you also probably want that there
couldn't be bizarre coincidences where
one thread happens to use a similar seed
to another one then they both happen to
be polluting the same purportedly random
numbers unless you want reproducibility
if you want them to have separate things
and so that's the idea that we mentioned
sort of very briefly of random numbers
streams and so that's the property that
linear congruential generators have that
if you use a different additive constant
you get a different stream completely
different sequence of random numbers
there's still you've all have them on a
grid it would still look almost
identical but this is a different it is
a different sequence and things built on
the new car and two generators get that
same property and in fact what PCG
unique does is it uses the memory
address of the state to to say okay I'll
use that to work out what my additive
constant is and so every memory address
every every memory just becomes its own
state and so you can trivially give
every every thread a different sequence
without anything without any trouble at
all and so that's that's kind of a neat
anything for if you're if you're working
in in parallel yes any comments party
Brandon was on the Intel CPUs the the
interesting thing is that they use
they're supposed to be coming out with
an actual thing that uses transistor
based noise but that isn't what's in
there right now the ones that are in the
Intel CPUs right now is actually using
an algorithm and it's just saying you
can't see the state but then that's kind
of status if you call our dear and it's
way slower than running many of these
you know including that notice the PCG
but but other other things it's not it's
essentially falling back to doing stuff
that's implemented in micro code and
it's not it's not fast at all and so
it's it's kind of a bizarre thing that
you have an instruction called Rd R and
as you like produce a random number
anything well that's a processor
instruction it should be fast but it's
like he these these other random number
generators can produce like PCG can
generate
I've run a number in less than a
nanosecond and so that's that's really
it's really cool that you know it can do
like a multiply and add and and some
shifts and stuff and so little time and
it's kind of sad that like this micro
coded instruction can't beat that but
presumably they intend not to optimize
so it could be you could use audio end
as a seat yeah and you can use you can
use other things you can use it you can
use ID around you can use the timestamp
counter you didn't even use a bunch of
things too that are probably you know
fairly fairly random but there are the
other thing I was not talking about the
time zone County yes anything way like
for any application the question is is
random number generation going to be
your bottleneck so for some things it's
absolutely not absolutely not a
bottleneck at all but suppose for
example you want to you pick something
really simple like quicksort one of the
one variation of quicksort is quicksort
is a randomized algorithm where you
choose the pivot at a random point and
so you can use that that variant of of
PCG but sorry of quicksort but whether
you would use it or not depends on how
fast you generate random numbers because
if you don't if you don't if you if it
takes you a long time you'd be better
off with some other non randomized
strategy so whether a randomized
algorithm is viable at all can depend on
the speed of your random number
generator and so fast ones are our net
positive and so in that that's an
example where whether a randomized
quicksort is faster it's worth using it
all depends on how fast you're under
number generator is and obviously it's
also the case that if you go if you if
you have something where random number
generation is not really the bottleneck
whether your thing takes 1 and 1/2
milliseconds or half an in a second I
made no difference at all
and so that's that's an area where it
might not be better to be to be faster
the cool thing about the PCG family is
that it gives pretty much no matter what
you want it's there for you so it's if
you want fast it is actually really fast
if you want statistically good it's
really statistically good if you want
compact it's actually really compact and
if you for some reason you really love
those gigantic periods and k-dimensional
equal distribution we can go we've got
you covered there too and if you want
unpredictability we've got some really
want that are really hard to predict
because because the way they treat
things and drop some of the bits making
the permutation really hard to undo so
it's not is not easy to predict unlike
many of these these other ones so if you
don't we if you want a hard to predict
fast small big and Adam statistically
good got you covered on all of those and
so that's the that is that is why a
number of people are quite excited about
it any other any other questions yes
which instructions yes that's that's
another option right there meaning in in
the because they've thrown a bunch of
hardware at doing a yes you can you
could say well if I've got really fast
AES permutations I could use those I
could use those too one of the one of
the things is that the the fundamental
idea in PCG is just saying we'll use a
simple simple generator that has some
really nice properties and then add
permutations on the top his here are
some good permutations but it's not
saying that that those are the only ones
that you can that you can use and so if
you have a thing that does IES
permutations really really fast then
that could be a good solution but the
things the alias permutations are
designed to be really like the caller
are overkill to make it impossible that
anyone could sort of figure out what
happened to the bit so they kind of go
around in crazy ways and so it's
even though there's hardware
implementations that make it make it
first part of the point of of PSG's it's
trying to do trying to get good
randomness with as little work as
possible there's not there's not a lot
to be said for having something that
does more work you know you could do
things that are more work than you need
but why do more work than you need to
you're trying to get as much bang for
buck
you